مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في مجزملاء من قناه
الجزيره اخفق وزراء الطاقه الاوروبيون
خلال اجتماعا في بروكسيل في الاتفاق على
تحديد سقف لاسعار الغاز واجر الوزاره
الاوروبيون حسم موضوع تحديد سقف لاسعار
الغاز الى اجتماعهم يوم الاثنين المقبل
وتواجه فرنسا والمانيا ودوله شمال اوروبا
تقسم شديد البروده ادى الى زياده الطلب
على الطاقه وذكر موقع
باردا في اوروبا الدائره ارتفاع اسعار
الكهرباء حيث يوازن المشغل والشبكه بين
الامداد والدفع لمحطات الطاقه للحفاظ على
اضواء المنطقه
قال مسؤولون
امريكيون عنه واشنطن قد تعلن ارسال هذه
الصواريخ الى اوكرانيا خلال الاسبوع
الجاري على ان يتم تدريبه الاوكرانيين على
استخدامها في قاعده الجيش الامريكي
بالمانيا وكان مسؤولون روسا هددوا
باستهداف منظومه الدفاع الجوي باتل في حال
تم تسليمها للسلطات الاوكرانيه
الخارجيه البريطانيه في تغريده ان رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني اعلن حزمه دعم للدفاع
الجوي لاوكرانيا بقيمه 50 مليون جنيه
استرليني اضافت ان حسبه المساعدات الجديده
لاوكرانيه تتالف من 125 مدفعا مضاده
للطائرات وتكنولوجيا لمواجهه مسيرات
الايرانيه
اعلنت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
في مؤتمر باريس للتضامن مع اوكرانيا
تعاهدوا بتقديم اكثر من مليار يورو لكيف
كدعم ماليا وعينيا خلال فصل الشتاء الجاري
وكشفت عن وضع اليه جديده سميت اليه باريس
لتنظيم وتنسيق الدعم الدولي والمساعدات
لاوكرانيا جاء ذلك في ختام اعمال المؤتمر
بمشاركته 46 دوله و24 منظمه دوليه من
بينها الامم المتحده
منتخب الكنيست باغلبيه صوتا يا ريف لافين
من حزب الليكويد رئيسا مؤقتا للكنيست بعد
عزل الرئيس الحالي نيكيليفي المحسوب على
حكومه تصريف الاعمال واسعا لكم الى
السيطره على الكنيست لتمرير تعديلات
قانونيه قبل الاعلان عن تشكيل حكومه
اطفاء الشرعيه على تعيين رئيس حركه شاس
المدني
في منصب وزاريا وادخال تعديلات تمكن عضوي
الكنيسه المتطرفين لتثمر بن كثير وايه
اسرائيل من توسيعه صلاحياتهما في وزارتي
الامن القومي والدفاع
وسط مخاوف متصاعده من صعود الاحزاب
الدينيه قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
المكلف ان اسرائيل لن تتحول في عهده الى
دوله اصول دينيه بل ستبقى دوله لكل
مواطنها وفق تعبيره
في خطوه تؤذن بتحول تاريخيا في انتاج
الطاقه النظيفه بما فيها الكهرباء قالت
وزيره الطاقه الامريكيه علماء امريكيين
تمكنوا لاول مره في التاريخ من تحقيق
اندماج النووي
نتجت عنه طاقه اكبر من الطاقه التي
يحتاجها اندماج اضافه الوزيره الامريكيه
ان الاعجاز العلمي الجديد يمكن من انتاج
طاقه نظيفه مشيره الى انه ثمره استثمار
الامريكيه في المختبرات والدراسات في هذا
المجال
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينتها الموجز في امان الله